is it true that beginning writers need
the most help with structure no oh you
all I think all writers need help with
structure okay I think there are writers
right now who are employed and writers
rooms who have soules features before
and they need help with structure I
definitely do and the way that you know
that that's true is because there are
Ari writers who have jobs a lot of the
times when someone sells a feature just
because they sold it doesn't mean that's
the way it's gonna make it onto the
screen right so they may buy it because
they like the idea they may buy it
because they like the characters they
may buy it because they like the world
they may buy it because they like you
you never know things happen but before
that thing goes to the next round
they're gonna hire someone else to come
in and tighten it up to come in and
restructure to come in and give it what
it needs and this is something that I do
as well I work with a lot of writers who
have something great on the page but
structurally speaking it's not hitting
the beats that it needs to hit like when
you if your script gets on someone's
desk finally makes it in they're gonna
have their intern or their assistant
read it first somebody who may or may
not have ever written a thing in their
lives somebody who may or may not have a
degree someone who may have just gotten
their day one and they're gonna be the
people who read your script they're
gonna have to read the entire thing
because that's their job and then
they're gonna write coverage on it which
means they're gonna say this is good
this is bad this is ugly these are what
the characters are executive you should
or you should not read it that's
basically what the coverage is going to
do the executive will then say okay
they're gonna take it and because they
have eight million scripts on their desk
they're gonna give it about 10 to 15
pages to hit particular beats before
they decide to continue to read there's
kind of like a industry standard of you
got to give it at least the 10 first 10
or 15 pages some people including myself
can give it three pages and know this
isn't gonna it's not gonna do what it's
supposed to do but because I'm a script
consultant I almost have to read you
know everything so I usually can't just
give it a few pages I have to read
everything so that I can give detailed
notes about what's going on but as far
as an executive goes they know what
they're looking
first of all wherever it is they're
working has a brand so if they're at Fox
they're not gonna buy what CBS would buy
they're not gonna buy what NBC would buy
they're not gonna buy what own would buy
they each have their own brand their own
audiences and things that they're
looking for so outside of looking for
those story beasts are also looking for
but would we put this on our channel
because regardless to how great it is if
it's not something that would be on
their channel they're not going to
continue to read it it's a waste of
their time to continue to read it so
with that being said structure matters
as far as Hollywood goes if you're an
independent writer an independent
producer independent director you can
write what you want to write and make
what you want to make because it's your
money but as far as Hollywood goes there
are particular things that they're
looking for if we haven't hit that
inciting incident around page 15 they're
not gonna keep reading when I used to
teach at Florida State
I taught intro to film and the whole
class was we would watch films and then
they would have to analyze them in the
written form and I would always say if I
get your essay and I haven't hit the
thesis statement I would even give them
the whole page even though we all know
these are statement should be in the
first paragraph but if I get to the
bottom of page one and I haven't gotten
to the thesis statement I'm not
continuing to read because you're making
me guess what your paper is about I
shouldn't have to guess what it's about
you should tell me this is what this
thing is about or this is what I'm going
to try to prove to you or whatever
that's what the inciting incident is for
the screenplay for you to give me the
information of this is what this thing
is about this is what my character is
going to be doing for all of act 2 or
this is what goal my character is trying
to reach in the resolution if I can't
know that by page 15 I'm not gonna keep
looking for it you know and so that's
why structure matters and there are some
people who don't who write who naturally
write well and don't know that they're
writing in that structure and then there
are some people who have great ideas and
great characters and great worlds and
the reason that the things aren't
selling or aren't doing what they need
to do is because they don't have any
structure so I think everybody can learn
from structure every single person some
people the people who
mastered it are those people who are
consistently making money as writers
because if you understand structure you
can write anybody story not just your
own and a lot of us think that being a
writer is all about writing our own
ideas and there are some people who get
to that level that their writing their
own ideas but most professional writers
people who are consistently getting paid
are people who are being hired by
producers to write for them or hire to
do rewrites on somebody else's stuff or
someone who can jump from writers room
to writers room to writers room and
continue to go up in in rank in those
writers rooms because they can hear
someone else's story and because they
know structure they can make it happen
so structure is just going to be helpful
all the way around is there one
structure upon which almost every story
will fit into there are several
different types of structures and it
depends on what kind of story you're
telling
so we have three act structure and
that's the one that almost everybody
knows and in my opinion three act
structure is the best to know because
even if you're writing in five acts all
it means is that you're stretching out
your 3x right or if you're writing in 2x
you're convincing your 2x or for those
those people who are into theater if
you're writing a one-act play your three
acts is happening in one act so
understanding three act structure which
basically means you pick you spend one
act on setting up you spend one act on
actually getting to the to the goal and
you spend another act on saying hey I
got the goal now what and that's
basically what the struck what structure
is so a lot of people will write pages
and pages and pages of activity but
activity is not action right action is
intentional right people are taking
intentional steps towards a goal
activity is just anything I went to a
party I sat in my house I watch TV I did
X Y & Z but if that isn't attached to
you actually trying to reach a goal than
what am i watching I'm watching the 12
hours of a reality TV show when someone
just sat there all day and filmed let's
say they were filming us right now what
would they be seeing just you sitting
here right but what does that mean
however if they were filming about how
what it takes for you to make your show
happen
now this becomes an intentional part of
the story but if the story is about you
going to the grocery store today then
why would we need to be showing this
right so yes there is one particular
structure that if everybody learns it's
gonna be helpful to you but most
features are written in three acts
someone our dramas urban in three acts
some are written in five and in comedies
half-hour comedies those can be written
in 2x or also three acts depending upon
what kind of comedies they are
single-camera comedies are usually done
in three acts multi-camera comedies
might be done in two so what I say to
people is going back to that homework
going back to honing your craft is read
scripts that are close to the script
that you're writing so that you can see
what kind of structure and what kind of
format they use because even the format
can change from features to TV from one
hour to half-hour so in order to know
that and those are those things where
it's like well I'm gonna walk in on my
date on my first day and be showrunner
it's like yes but you don't know that
there's a different format between
half-hour multi-camera comedy and a
single-camera comedy that's information
that you should probably know if you're
gonna run the show right and the
information is out there because now we
live in 2020 and there's YouTube there's
Instagram and there are people who are
giving the information away for free so
when people don't take the opportunity
to use utilize those resources then
that's when I go back to you got to
respect the craft
you